lo que quiere hacer en este vídeo es
enfatizar la relación o conexión entre
fracciones y divisiones y usar ese
conocimiento para ayudarnos a
simplificar algunas fracciones
peliagudas repasemos un poco primero
digamos que tenemos estos dos que es
dividido entre 3 2 entre 3
yo puedo escribir esto como 2 sobre 3
esta expresión de aquí podemos a veces
decir que es dos tercios pensarla como
una fracción pero también la podemos ver
como 2 que es dividido entre 3 y podemos
hacer lo opuesto si alguien nos dice que
tenemos 4 novenos o 4 sobre 9 podemos
interpretarlo como 4 que es dividido
entre 9 y de hecho si quisiéramos
convertir esto a decimales es
exactamente lo que tendríamos que hacer
esta división 4 dividido entre 9 ahora
vamos a usar este conocimiento para
algunas fracciones un poco más complejas
tomemos este ejemplo de acá
alguien nos dice que tenemos dos en
lugar de tres digamos que es dos sobre
dos tercios como podemos simplificar
esto pues podemos decir que esto es un 2
que es dividido entre dos tercios vamos
a escribirlo así 2 dividido entre dos
tercios y esto es exactamente lo mismo
que recordemos que dividir entre una
fracción es lo mismo que multiplicarla
por su recíproco esto es lo mismo que 2
por el recíproco de dos tercios para
sacar el recíproco invertimos el
numerador con el denominador y nos queda
tres medios dos por tres medios si tengo
tres medios dos veces pues va a ser
igual a seis medios
y para simplificar estos dos medios es
un entero entonces aquí tengo tres
enteros o seis dividido entre dos que
nos da igual a tres vamos a hacer más
ejemplos y vamos a hacerlos un poquito
más complicados cada vez ya que esto va
a ser una muy buena práctica y como
siempre pausa el vídeo para tratar de
resolverlos por su cuenta
en verdad deben sentirse emocionados
cuando vean este tipo de cosas y traten
de resolverlo por su cuenta
bueno hagamos algo bastante interesante
tenemos menos 16 sobre 9 sobre 3 entre 7
o 3 sobre 7 que es esto pueden
simplificar esta expresión de aquí claro
que si nuevamente podemos expresar esto
como menos dieciséis novenos entre tres
séptimos así que re escribo esto y puedo
ponerlo como menos 16 entre 9
o escribir lo como menos dieciséis
novenos puedo poner el signo negativo en
frente de toda la fracción o puedo decir
que es menos 16 sobre 9 y 16 sobre menos
9 es exactamente lo mismo y ahora esto
lo vamos a dividir entre 3 séptimos
y esto va a ser igual a menos 16 novenos
es más vamos a escribirlo como menos 16
entre 9 simplemente para mostrar que
podemos hacerlo multiplicado por el
recíproco de esto multiplicado por 7
tercios sólo intercambien el numerador
con el denominador por 7 tercios y ahora
que voy a tener en el numerador tengo
menos 16 que voy a multiplicar por 7 10
por 7 70 6 por 7 es 42 70 más 42 es
igual a 112 así que esta parte de aquí
va a ser igual a menos 112 sobre 9 por 3
nos va a dar 27 9 por 13 27 y aquí lo
tenemos podemos verlo como menos 112
entre 27 o podemos poner el signo
negativo al frente de toda la expresión
y decir que tenemos menos 112 27 ambos
y para conectar esto con lo que
mencionamos al principio podemos ver
esto como 112 dividido entre 27 o como
menos 112 27 a vos
ambas son correctas